there you go easy lollipop
inch park home of edinburgh south
cricket club you took it nice and high
so you could recover
they'll let you know after 15 that
they're falling behind there's no record
of racism here but the same can't be
said for the sport in scotland as a
whole
ask the coach mental health suffered
definitely probably affected my first
marriage first couple of years because i
was just a shell of myself okay guys
we're going straight into the drill
kasim sheikh is the cricketer who
prompted a review of the game and its
governance
he and record wicket taker majid hack
claimed that their skin colour limited
their opportunities in cricket and ended
their careers prematurely sky news has
learned that the independent review into
racism in the game echoes their concerns
on publication it will say that
institutional racism runs through
scottish cricket
i feel it's more of a subtle
racism
not necessarily slurs directed at me
more treatment being different to
[Music]
white counterparts quite often and not
just me
many other many other players as well
through the pathway feel that you know
we were treated differently
careers ended from
raising any concerns or saying anything
never to play again
the findings in this report extend
beyond the world of cricket they are now
a police matter
multiple referrals have been made
regarding alleged racist behavior to a
number of organizations including police
scotland
the world t20 trophy is currently on
tour officials from cricket scotland
were parading it in edinburgh this
weekend
their issues with racism follow a
similar scandal that engulfed yorkshire
cricket in recent years
scotland's problem hasn't gone unnoticed
by some within the game who've set up a
pressure group called running out racism
there are very few coaches of asian
descent um
in in in the performance setup yet
there's very very many at grassroots
level
there are very few on committees
and so the game is uh is significantly
represented at the grassroots level in
terms of its diversity but where
decisions happen
it very much isn't
in a statement qriket scotland said
cricket should be a welcoming place for
everyone and not somewhere that racism
or any form of discrimination takes
place the cricket scotland board is
truly sorry to everyone who has
experienced racism in cricket in
scotland
it is cricket's uneven playing field a
dark secret
[Music]
called out
james matthews sky news edinburgh